what is the machine supposed to be doing
while it's leading us into World War III
what I think what the media machine is
supposed to be doing is questioning
things right it's given me it's given me
a great Avenue to have a career right
because they seem completely incapable
of doing their job but there's plenty of
other people who are now
looking at the mainstream media and
going man I wish you just weren't that
terrible and I always say it it's like I
don't even think the mainstream media
has to be particularly good I think they
just have to not be abjectly awful but
they seem un uh incapable of doing that
another guy who's been getting this and
I think has really built an incredible
career off it is Joe Rogan and here he
is going off on mainstream media
that used to be that the media was the
primary place that people would go to
find out what's going on in the world
but now the media conveniently leaves
out anything that it doesn't want to be
at the front and center in in terms of
like things that people concentrate on
and talk about you know all it is is
like January 6th January 6th did you see
what they did January
Trump is coming back but January 6th
looms large how about the fact that the
guy who's the president right now can't
form a sentence he makes up
words and stumbles through things no one
says a goddamn thing about it
yeah so there's Rogan just laying out
the basic truths that I try to lay out
here every day there is a huge
disconnect between what is getting
fed To Us by the mainstream media the
corporate press the Democrat politicians
and then what reality is on the ground
so you know what we need we need new
voices we need new Fighters we need new
platforms we need New Media we need to
knew all of it as I always say and we
can do it
[Music]
thank you